[Music]
to push my life's a party but kiss
please don't smoke crack words to live
by from the bush man that's true he
couldn't join us he tried to take a bus
here to Phoenix you don't know we're
coming to you live from Phoenix and
we're recording from Phoenix that the
ATC pop-up podcast studio at downtown
Phoenix at the all things comedy
festival presented by Bud Light
cityscape and Tito's handmade vodka oh
[ __ ] Erin may need to cut that and send
that into a voiceover agency thank you
everybody
[ __ ] madman O'Neill over these guys
looking in the window come on inside
don't be a creep we're not going to show
you our [ __ ] but we're case you're not
here in the live audience like the
thousands of people who are this is even
bigger than our downtown LA pod fest
that I'd like audience what was that
1,800 yeah this is over two thousand
what we're following there's a fire
marshal telling people to clear out of
the aisles sir here's a handshake with
some money in it can they stay oh he
said yes cool what we're following is
Ari she fears balls and penis and boy I
think the icing on the cake was when
Doug Stanhope urinated on Ari yeah Wow
right right there right where you
sitting no not right where I'm sitting
how dare you it was nearby it was in the
vicinity in the vicinity but I'm not
gonna sit in Doug Stanhope is pissed at
us or his body which is probably worse
than Doug Stanhope is pissed
that's a legend you're talking about who
re no Harry or is the furthest thing
from legend thank you guys for coming
out how many how many people here have
heard of us by round of applause wow wow
this this lady even not even Eric the
comedy store managers heard of us yeah
he has he's one of our biggest fans I
don't know if that's true you've never
seen him in the studio he's never talked
to me once
really yeah maybe after this is your
chance it's hot as hell in here is it me
it is very hot I think it's the piss is
warming me out I don't know the ground
floor how come you guys aren't at home
watching the Michael Jackson Halloween
special did you see that was on tonight
the Michael Jackson Halloween special is
it like is it officially past time we're
like all right let's forget about all
that was talked about and now let's
celebrate him again he's like at the
Roman Polanski level I think he is
like enjoys music again Harvey
Weinstein's a piece of [ __ ] let's
celebrate this man on Halloween who's
with us I don't know if that's true
these people didn't even want to watch
it a lot of tattoos in the audience I
like it yeah weird tattoo heavy on you
so listens to us is that our demographic
yeah we we attract that demographic we
need that to artists as a sponsor we
have good light all right drew let's get
into the goddamn show whoa such
profanity it's f you saw what happened
here earlier I know we have to come out
guns a-blazing to match the intensity
that happened here what should we go
with here it's a lot of good stuff I
know what I should go with what do you
got I got something out of Wales online
who here knows of well is that a is that
like a wildlife publication there's this
whales the whales the is that a country
our people as well as a country
everybody's it part of its part of
England everybody here is there shaking
your head people like don't call on me I
don't know the answer is it a city it's
not a city a state of the country I
think it's where well I don't I don't
know why we're turning to you but
somehow you are the authority on this
he's the crowd leader why am I so they
sent me to a site called manga win it
looks like tuxedos for children I don't
want to try a tuxedo how do I get out of
here that's the worst name for a [ __ ]
tuxedo place penguin all right this is
Wales online this is from a dude named
Michael is that Paula Deen's Michael I
think it might be Paula Deen's
ex-husband this is a great court case
you don't know the Danish no Neil show
these to people Metallica Johnny and his
lady with the tit tattoos if you don't
know the we do a lot of current events
and so you're gonna walk out of here a
lot smarter than you came in but also a
great deal dumber well if you want to be
negative about it I'm going to be okay
so this is about on his former college
lecturer apparently he's been convicted
of masturbating while driving around a
supermarket car parking garage okay who
hasn't been pulled over for that and
he's secretly filming women using a
caravan what does that mean a minivan
yeah yeah yeah okay
or is it it maybe to Dodge Caravan that
could be good sponsorship for this guy
driving around jerking it you think he's
gonna get a deal out of this
so a jury at this this site is horrible
god damn it Erin I blame you for this I
don't
jury at Swansea Court on Wednesday found
Anthony George rumble you got to get his
name out there bundle yeah the old
Rundle the terrible has with the name
like that you're gonna drive around
jerking it off yeah you were born for
this he's 51 if you guys want to know
how old he is to be jerking it in public
it's a little too old to be jerkin maybe
it took him 50 years though to work up
to this level of confidence do you think
that he took enough courage to hop in
that minivan
hey baby today is today I'm gonna go out
there and jerk it in the minivan listen
to where he's from he's from glebe lands
Johnston near Haverfordwest
it all sounds like Harry Potter this is
why we fought the English yeah yeah so
we don't have to deal with their stupid
[ __ ] name it's too many goddamn name
for a place to live that's why that's
what drives you to drive around jerking
off in public
when you have to write that down on
every like online thing you're doing any
letter you mail you're like here's the
return address in a collaboration all
the way across the object that's why
their envelopes are way longer in
England shockingly he was found
unanimously guilty of two counts of
indecent exposure and for a voyeurism
what yeah
which you've been doing lately by the
way if you guys listen to the show and
you look his neighbors windows like
Burma look okay I'm doing this as an
intervention for you know that guy
towels his balls off in the window
across from my apartment we're talking
about O'Neal's neighbor he does not know
this much about this British guy yet
know that how is that voyeurism I Larry
walk out the door and that's what I see
you don't have to use binoculars but I
prefer to when I leave the house I like
to walk out with night-vision scope
strapped to my head you're keeping them
honest but you're also looking for
longer than you probably should okay
yeah okay if you see what are you
supposed to immediately turn away so
find one half count of voyeurism
I'll take that what is that a
misdemeanor are you gonna plead out yeah
I'll plea deal this how okay two six
months probation
so old Rundle who had a clean previous
care
there which is a weird way of putting
record in England clean character
apart from being cautioned in 2000 do
you say 2002 2002 you probably of being
found drunk in public I denied all the
charges he said he was not jerking off
while driving around in a van but they
found him jerking off yeah now like this
guy's style deny deny deny the
prosecutor said on March 12 a shopper
visiting the Tesco store big shout out
to the Tesco shoot the [ __ ] this test or
no test go I don't know but it's in
cardigan if you want to go there no I
don't ever wear a cardigan saw the
English Rundle I don't why are they
saying he's English we know he's English
[ __ ] is going on here drive slowly past
with his trousers around his knees as
genitals exposed which I don't know a
serious commitment though when you go
down around the knees I've never been to
England I don't know if that's like how
they all drive probably not jerk it off
no like with your trousers around your
knees yeah I wouldn't go around the
knees like you you can go down halfway
down the thigh and still jerk it while
you're driving do you think you like
with this this wasn't plan cuz you would
just wear shorts wouldn't you you think
this is an impromptu he's weird as a god
this ride home is making me so horny
them all i could drive around look at
all these bloody birds penis ain't gonna
wake itself that is a good point but and
maybe he's a classy guy he doesn't wear
shorts I'm gonna say he's not a classy
I'm sorry but I'm gonna disagree
it's a weeks later a female worker at
the Marks & Spencer store these are
horrible names by the way we should go
to England just name things to be heroes
I like how England left the Union but
the Union may have just thrown him out
for these types of names the stores at
with a bush Haverfordwest
which it's a girthy and witty bush [ __ ]
she saw Rundle with his right hand on
the steering wheel he's a lefty and his
left hand on his penis
that is a nod straight I mean that's an
odd beat style he was like it was like
this yeah I know but also oh you know
what though
yeah but they drive on the right hand
side so he's getting more elbow action
for stronger strokes there's time here
genes around his knees
how's he driving the pedals you could
get caught up in the genes yeah there's
a lot of safety hazards going on you
think he drives a stick no pun intended
no if he did then you'd almost have to
let him off just for being able to
manage all those things at once he got
arrested ten days later and just to be
safe they removed his computers selling
of Georgia door that really allows them
to come in and take your [ __ ]
computer I guess so oh my god so his
defense is unbelievable they found four
different videos each having been filmed
by a camera focused on what appeared to
be the bathroom you can't get away with
anything now oh you like complain about
how dare you take away our rights to
jerk off in our cars so the jury heard
two of the films that showed women
removing their clothes before taking
showers in all four videos the private
parts of the woman could be seen Breton
Biddle comb giving beer I don't know if
that's legal but we approve of it say
his first and last name do you have a
liquor license yes I'll take one of
those well by the way when asked for an
explanation for the video is by police
Rundle said the women involved were
exhibitionists and he planned it as a
joke
the old gag defense yeah I'm taking
video the way showering as a [ __ ] gas
yeah you really think I'm doing this
it's me Rundle okay so a prankster
remember I killed that guy in 87 yoke he
he was gonna film them as a joke and put
the footage on the internet to show to
show how stupid they were in quotes
Ashton Kutcher of England he's gonna
show them oh my god so that what kind of
defense is that it's the work you're
[ __ ] psycho
it's the Johnnie Cochran of things like
I get you go with the prank defense fine
but then you're going to I'm gonna post
it show of what idiots they are I don't
think that's legal no it's not
so Rundle that wasn't going so well so
he
for the pity for a pity plea he suffers
from spina bifida from birth so he
starts throwing that out there yo here
we go come on guys the old spina bifida
defense and he has a prosthetic leg and
urinary problems didn't Oh J try this
one before the defend he did if the
spina bifida doesn't fit you got to let
him go I think it went he said he
couldn't remember the car places where
he filmed but he was probably preparing
to urinate when the women saw him
touching his penis yeah he was getting
ready you don't when you up the piss you
don't get your dick out in the car of
course I pull it around my knees and
warm it up a little bit yeah you're not
gonna go out there cold and I will only
piss with a boner by the way who in here
doesn't yeah that's the only way to do
it I think how a classy person does it
this is so packed in here I see three
guys pissing with boners in front of us
have you ever gone to like a baseball
game this guy's got a boner right now he
said write a penny said boner city I've
I've gone next two guys who have huge
boners while they're pissing in urinals
were you a child it just sprays all over
the top and then sprays all over them as
a child my dad took me to Fenway Park
just to pee yeah it's the only place
that you would piss he bought a ticket
cuz my mom threw him and me out and so
he's like I still live in Fenway Park
but they had the troughs yeah and as a
child my eye was right at dick level and
you just see grown men like in a
procession line and that's why I can't
piss in public what were you standing in
the trough I think I had to get a step
stool
I remembered seat like you looked down
and it's just a row of [ __ ] just
pissing it's a beautiful sight because
it was Boston in the 80s it was all
white I don't think they Boston mm still
all white that's true big shout out to
Boston so so yeah we love you racist
keep it up guys
Randall said I wasn't masturbating but I
don't deny showing hey when you try to
do kill me I'll take one of those hey
why are you taking you've won in front
of you I did hear you all right free
beer free beers these weren't being
passed out for punch-drunk that shitty
podcast
nothing but [ __ ] vulgarity those
genitals they're all bud lights by the
way proud sponsor of the not so proud
after the punch-drunk podcast but
they're back to being proud of the all
things comedy festival so Rundle said I
wasn't masturbating but I don't deny
showing my penis I always try to find
somewhere quiet but it's not always
possible to show it or to pee to piss
but it was always possible by the way
brother to find a quiet place to urinate
lives in the busiest city of 1 year old
he lives in China I don't get why it was
out while he was driving and he's like
yes there's a lot of issues first it was
a joke by the way he doesn't need to say
anything more he just admitted that he
videotaped these girls as a pranked and
humiliate them I gave his lawyer credit
for just not this guys defending himself
I don't think so I don't know if this
guy had a lawyer so the prosecutor
showed a map of the parking lot which
highlighted three different areas he'd
stopped in before a woman's shop or
caught him so he was really looking for
a spot to piss for a long time it was
like Christmastime he to really circle
the lotto quiet places no it was the
last time I come to this mall to pitch
the prosecutor said I would imagine any
occasion you were caught sure it would
have been embarrassing for you wouldn't
it and then she said you say here a
discreet man you think then that these
occasions would have been quite
memorable to you you had your left hand
on your penis moving it up and down this
lady's really grilling them this is like
Tom Cruise and a few good men I want the
dick you can't handle it you just
warming the shaft up a little bit you
gotta take a piss you want a warm [ __ ]
the prosecutor said Runnels motivation
and all the offences was simply sexual
gratification I don't believe it I'm
with Rundle on this his defender he's
doing the Lord's work this is a weird
name Dai fed Thomas dyf Edie where'd he
get this guy I don't know is this guy on
the trolleys he may know him from
meetings he goes to yeah [ __ ] shower
meetings said his client a genuine
genuine health issues which affected his
ability to urinate normally and this
could have been what witnesses saw way
it's gang health issues ladies pissing
in his car there's no reason that his
dick should be out maybe he pisses out
the window has anyone here ever had
their dick out in their car
three guys is this guy she's looking
around other people you think I don't
want to be the first to raise my hand
but I'll be the second who the guy in
the Slayer shirt or the guy in there her
no right there the her leash layer now
Slayers like no way
Hurley looks like a lifeguard who like
got fired for something no looks like a
volleyball coach high school of course
intramural like I'm just donating my
time to these kids so they're trying to
argue that because this guy has a
catheter he has a cat that's what they
were seeing
oh you think why is he filming people
for the prank okay this could be the
worst luck maybe it's bow also why do
you need a quiet place to piss we have a
catheter take the hose out the window
and drive that's not legal
yeah just looks like somebody's
everything a hose out do you think he'd
ever tried to kill himself by putting
the hose in and just trying to fill the
car up until he dies right tie that hose
around his neck this guy's the [ __ ]
prankster I want to hang out with him
like this he have a YouTube page where
he's posting this stuff I don't know but
they said regarding the voyeurism
offences the defenders like alright he
accepts that he made the films they're
gonna they're gonna give in to that
where they're trying to get out of this
jerk in charge prosecution says he did
it to get sexual gratification yeah you
said that he said it was a joke
and later except that it was wrong you
know what he's learned his lesson let
him go yeah come on spina bifida for
Christ let him go back to Tesco you
don't want this guy you don't want to
support this guy's medical costs in your
UK prison he said to the jury if he was
really stupid and took the films from a
warped sense of humor then you'd have to
find him not guilty which is a weird
stance on that this guy was granted bail
but he's due to be sentenced in three
weeks Eric just walked out on us from
the Comedy Store great very typical well
it's probably his mopeds probably
getting towed that is true he does Drive
a man who just left grown man drives a
moped around town an errand our sound
man just left what is happening sky
everyone's walking out on is he on
strike he's getting a phone call it's
getting a text from somebody maybe he
didn't like seeing them probably is mom
watching live on YouTube she's like you
need to quit that show Erin you went to
sound college for this yeah it's an
watch people urinate on each other
so I think this guy's going away I don't
know I don't know fingers crossed this
guy lives the final Malda pissin again
you think who here thinks he'll be
guilty but I think he was guilty already
this guy you think he's guilty [ __ ]
you got no way this guy walks
you think he'll walk no he'll never walk
you spina bifida now it's true that hit
him one that hit him below the belt
while he was missing he's I don't even
know what it is but something tells me
it leads you to not walking again you
think he's just started this or he just
got caught for the first time and this
is he's too much of an amateur this is
his first go at this you think yeah
you think it'll try it again anything
he's done I mean there's no way that
some guys just drive around for people
song well the damning part is the video
you think now the video he may have a
shot it's the prosthetic leg a jury's
sympathetic for that you just take it
off and slam it down on the table in
front of it maybe intentionally got
spina bifida just so yes i sympathy from
the court I don't know if that works
that was genetic but who knows alright I
think we need to pick up the pace here
yeah I see this guy stroking his beard
and that tells me to pick up the pace
how's that beard feels you have do you
have candy in there what are you trying
to get out oh this is the drive go-kart
clan bring the cars let's go in the
street my race tracks on the street if
you had a go-kart outside that would be
if you had to go carts just waiting
right out front be unbelievable and like
what tandem go karts are like separate
good no no separate go-karts like on the
back of a truck we just roll them down
and we just take off through the streets
of Phoenix you don't have that do your
earring plugs slowed you down in the
go-kart how big are you looking to go
with those those uh he's got saucers in
his ears that's it oh what a [ __ ] yeah
but although this guy in the back wants
to work up to what he has he has smaller
ones
there you are you envious of how big his
are this guy's just starting out it's
like his starter plates neither of you
could fit a penis through that ear hole
though which is a fun game to play
it's like operation if you can stay
through without touching any of the rims
I would get I would get him so big that
like when you go hiking they get caught
on tree branches like that's what I
would go for my girlfriend Courtney had
those and she was so ashamed when she
went to a target and sauced like a 40
year old man who had him that she took
them out on the spot look in the guy's
face oh really
it by the way I'm sure shamed of it but
then had to sell them clothes and that's
expensive so I'm closed all right Glenn
you may if you ever get those out you're
either gonna have a hole in your ear
like that or you're gonna have to sell
them up what are you gonna do you have
to do it right now you have to decide do
you want a phone a friend you look kind
of like GSP now that I look at him this
guy in the Hurley shirt which is great
audio I know he's doing GSP impressions
I like it there's like two three more
women in here than I imagined would come
to this I think they're brought here by
force by their significant other no you
oh [ __ ] this guy's be a problem it's why
he seems so unenthused he's like what is
this [ __ ] over so I think let's get to
another court case let's keep it in
Europe yeah
that's not Eric can't believe Eric
walked out on us he'll be Rex on his
moped our home comedy club you know that
guy I've been like the weirdest thing
ever be turned around we wave to this
huge [ __ ] guy who just watch yeah I
don't know if you're like looking for a
guy to fight later or what do you what
is that your Samoan bouncer who comes
everywhere with you and you're like
you're late [ __ ] alright let you
ready to we're gonna head to Berlin home
of your Nazi relative yeah I like it I
like staying in Europe we finally gotten
out of American horseshit oh yes ago
here's the greet this guy he's gonna
whip him oh how do you know this guy
he's like you better come say hello to
me in four minutes or I'm gonna kill you
yeah how do you guys know each other
they've been buddies for a while okay
people at home Jesus where are you from
sir local all right [ __ ] your big man
into that story he's a large man you
can't see him if you're listening at
home are you what's your nationality
it's Anna you're the tallest Hispanic
person ever sir oh [ __ ] man
I don't know if you've been around and a
lot of them aren't very tall and I'm a
Jew
I'm 6-3 so I know what it's like me and
you were like the matumbo is of our
races Jesus Christ that's a lot of if
you ever want to be a drug mule you got
a lot of area that you can [ __ ]
smuggle drugs in he's a huge [ __ ]
that's an insane tried to be friends
with them
you and him are wearing the same shirt
and I'm gonna say it's like this across
the neck with the younger that means
they'll kill you it's podcasts go last
five hours I'll outlast this guy he's
got to go home at some point
what do you mean I know but eventually
he's gonna have to like go home do
something probably what are you the
[ __ ] guy run those lawyers it's the
worst he's gonna have to take a dump or
something he's got to leave why would he
shows on he doesn't want to ruin it
he's got respect for the craft the guy
back there is 14 drinks in front of
those are all his is that product
placement sir did you drink those that's
a cry for help
yeah he's just waiting for someone who I
could talk about it I wish somebody
would have an intervention and care
about me for once all right so we're in
Berlin yeah this has been going on for
18 months this is a scandal that's
rocked the country okay it's not a
country it's a city well it's in a
country I'm not okay hello I know but I
didn't know if you were referring to
Berlin as a country maybe I was maybe I
wasn't
you'll never know so this has involved
23 officials there's been a court
appearance and there's even been
protests from a politician on the floor
of Berlin Senate okay it's uh it's an
unusual crime that I guess has been
committed here if it's a crime at all
what is it apparently this is all over a
fart
[Laughter]
so it's uh this goes back to last year
2016 in February officers from Berlin's
police unit 32 if you want to know what
unit they're representing okay they
demanded the documents of a group of
people in the cities some area it's in
Berlin nice the street formula it
formally populated by squats that
remained a rallying point for Berlin's
counterculture so I guess homeless
people are like [ __ ] yeah we want to
hang out here it's place where a City
lab is previously reported relations
between some locals and the police are
commonly little front the officials were
unprepared for the arrests arrestees
reaction I'm being asked for their IDs
one member of the group farted twice
once would be a mistake twice I believe
his intention yeah once shame on me
twice shame on you
furious that the officers honor was
under attack the police took action what
yeah how bad were these rippers I think
probably pretty bad and twice by the way
Berlin cops aren't taking farting
lightly great [ __ ] control to rip off
too that's who you want at your protest
these we walk them on the fart talk yes
not everybody can handle it alright yeah
go home bar talk now he's like I can't
believe we said to forty minutes of that
[ __ ]
you know what they paid to get in here
it's a free podcast yeah so uh after an
inexplicable delay of 12 months the
defendant received a fine for his
insulting behavior they waited you don't
think all these kids insult they waited
a year he got fined $1,000 that easy
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so Berlin now is
taking your right to fart away from you
yeah we think is we have the god-given
right people are saying it's bad here in
America I mean what was the guy checking
his [ __ ] and then he farted in his
face this is insane it was a woman cop
and he farted twice in front of her and
apparently that was a nothing to have
anything well if she was a male what if
a male cop he probably would've laugh I
don't know you said him I was just
correcting you I didn't say oh she don't
even know if it was a lady it wasn't
lady that's why I said it I was
correcting okay him okay
dare you I don't know what's going on
we're dis articles tearing us apart I
know uh this is a farticles this was
dubbed the crazy to trial by greasy to
trial who's maybe this rappers I think
seven year olds ah
the local media I guess called it that
it provokes an obvious question they
want to know is it worth bringing this
to try they brought this to try this is
a waste of the taxpayers money are you
kidding me
if I were a [ __ ] taxpayer in Berlin
I'd be like [ __ ] you guys this is insane
so at an East Berlin senator this week
the case he he wanted inquiry case took
up more than seventeen official working
hours just for this [ __ ] case
involving two farts it led nowhere
after refusing to pay this defendant
would not pay I like his style yeah you
shouldn't [ __ ] pay he was summoned to
what it says by the way that's the most
expensive fart of all time a thousand
dollars it's too so there are five
hundred okay so either way five dollars
for farts a lot
that's uh the pricey [ __ ] yeah he was
summoned to what may well be the
first-ever berlin court case that hinged
on a fart oh really yeah if there was
like more than one I don't know that's a
shock that isn't this is [ __ ] crazy
but I was the judge dismissed it in
under ten minutes I'm surprised it took
up dead [ __ ] this this is out what was
the ten-minute debate over it maybe it
was ten minutes late
showed up with 30 things like there's a
fart on my desk right now he's like
really the [ __ ] out of Berlin unit 32
come on guys that isn't what the [ __ ]
how pissed off they couldn't get
anything on these guys so he's busted
him for a fart this is insane here's the
twist police unit 32 they already have a
bad image they're already they're bad
cops they're just starting to live down
reports of orgiastic parties its
officers indulged in while providing
backup policing for the summer g20
summit in Hamburg
the police unit 32 was having orgies
well they were supposed to be guarding
the g20 so who who hired this police
force just would they just hire
fraternity I think so cuz officers while
they were there they got so drunk that
they urinated in masse against a fence
well one couple had sex in public and a
female officer danced on a table in a
bathrobe by the way we're cheated the
[ __ ] bathroom this Police Academy
Berlin five citizens on Patrol if that
wasn't enough she was dancing on the
table in a bathrobe brandishing her
revolver as she did this is where the
American cops put us up to this article
we beat an innocent man in shooter but
these [ __ ] animals
yeah they don't take farting lightly god
damn they just need to disband an entire
force it's insanity I think that I think
they should bring more people I still
don't know where the city had a [ __ ]
bathroom from she wears it under a
uniform be great like what is that
what's that rope a some people wear
bulletproof that drawstring some people
were a bathroom oh my god Aaron is still
not back which is alarming so we had a
major sound issue we're [ __ ]
who knows he has a wife doesn't he what
are you saying he needs to like leave
too maybe yeah maybe something happened
let's hope it's an emergency
let's hope something really bad just
about my wife I'm not saying that but I
mean for him to leave leave us hanging
like yeah it's very unprofessional here
he's coming back right we're gonna have
to grill him on this yeah what happened
Aaron this better be good
did you lose your license I hope your
identity was stolen he's not well we
don't want to dig too deep no Aaron is a
bad temper
yeah he's punched us before he has
abused us now we show can officially
start this guy just got here we were
waiting for you
we've been doing filler the whole time
everything we've done up to this point
sir is warmup
this guy's a big
our only black fan apparently he's a big
podcast agent really yeah this lady's
pointing at him like yeah he's black
we're talking about him miss the lady
the guy next to you he's like this guy
and like yeah that guy question from the
audience yeah oh yeah here let us start
from the beginning of the show and fill
you in everybody like would you like to
talk on the mic so the people at home
can hear you we only get 8 million
listeners per episode no pressure
she's with Hawaiian shirt Johnny he
looks like a cop from Berlin yeah he
does look undercover you can ask it in
the mic or you can ask it and we'll
repeat it she came in late what is this
guy court reporter and he's reading
everything back to you he's reading his
stenographer notes in Berlin yes sorry
he didn't fart on anything he just
farted twice in front of a cop in the in
the cops direction as they say twice and
they were arrested exactly yeah Monty
Python she just quoted it anything else
any follow-ups that's pretty much all
there is to the story there's nothing
out there's no you want to know M night
Shyamalan twist to this at all do you
want to says yes it's just they farted
he got arrested he doesn't want to pay
the ticket do you want us to go over
everything we've talked about from here
on cuz I mean which is not our fault you
couldn't find parking I'll tell you what
you had to pay a thousand dollar fine
but you refused to pay it yeah I know
that we're just as outraged as you want
welcome to the show yeah we're not
supporting yeah it's not like we're like
this guy should be thrown into jail look
at this guy I think this is a first date
for that guy and he's like oh yeah but
which guy I think Hawaiian shirt Eddie
oh okay
I think the black guy's just the
cameraman who's like I'll film you guys
from Craigslist why not he came in the
latest of them all not to be
stereotypical sir I'm not it's not a
racist Jesus it's the truth for Christ's
sakes
yeah but that's it man you have you've
gotten all of the information down fill
these three guys in please and what
happened
so uh guy farts twice in front of a cop
in Berlin it's $1,000 fun oh I brought
the guy and they let what happened you
have to leave your parking ran out
that's a lie
oh my you get in an uber will kill you
if I see if I see your meter flashing
green I'm gonna throw a brick through
your window if you get on a bus we'll
find you those tattoos are identifying
marks this guy right now is like what
the [ __ ] what's happening oh cool
thank you they're going to Arizona
daughter-in-law party what are you
trying to take our audience to your
[ __ ] party wait are you coming in or
promoting some other [ __ ] Club or
something she's a waitress is between
okay can we get the podcaster to medium
there we go
walk that door please hey lady was the
worst yeah first she interrupts the show
and then she's trying to get people to
go to someplace that was a great
deception cuz she was close to Hawaii
sure but she left with the black guy do
you know how do you know that lady oh
she was just turning to you for moral
support
you should have punched her Sara we
don't support that now violence on the
show yeah especially while we're
drinking Bud Lights which is delicious
and they're great for you if you
couldn't hear her at home she sounded
like this by the the Bud Light I'm
drinking fortified with vitamins and
minerals really yeah
they say babies should drink those every
now and that if that's that lady do not
let her in with a rip knee [ __ ] skin
oh we're getting FedEx packages
delivered now [ __ ] midnight look at
these FedEx guys working hard you guys
are doing the Lord's work my friend they
have a spotter with them as well yeah
third guy are you part of the crew hey
you guys ever argue over who gets to
drive the van I think we know who drives
the van it's the best dressed guy he's
like I'm not carrying [ __ ] these other
two guys will do look at that slicked
back hair man he's like we yeah does he
ever take a break too Reese lick that
he's doing it right now look at it's
pretty does it spur
do you just have like a 55-gallon drum
of just grease hey every 20 minutes use
Reese and just grease it again what time
do you guys get off like an 8 a.m.
no way you won't even let these guys
well let it call the Trib kidnapping my
friend I'm gonna call out I'm gonna call
out that was real white privilege you
notice the boss was a white man oh yeah
he made him stay yeah he said watch me
humiliate hey funny don't leave oh are
you going to that party that that later
on voting that son in the way you're
gonna go watch son-in-law starring Pauly
Shore across the street go ahead lady we
don't need your ripped skinny jeans
they're too tight that's why they're
it's not even Halloween you guess what
these three [ __ ] people filled those
seats welcome aboard
have you ever heard of the Danish
Antonio podcast oh they all pointed each
other like that oh you have you brought
these two people you new to the world of
Danish no Neil he's a shark on his
forearm you make that thing dance when
you jerk off okay shark is that the
sharknado it's a load catcher I don't
know yeah cool wait wait what is that
shark what does it mean any means you
get bit by a shark or anything you just
like give me that [ __ ] shark I want
it on my arm I wonder from off that wall
and on my [ __ ] arm
you get it on one of those discounted
nights not that it's bad work do you
know it on every Friday the 13th you can
line up in front of a tattoo shop and
get like a dollar tattoo everyone knows
that he runs a lot of people were
nodding I didn't know that Wow he didn't
teach me that in Hebrew school yeah okay
you have you heard of us sir okay did
you just wander in here cuz you're mad
at your wife that's a good question are
you supposed to be at the grocery store
right now are you want I just need to
place the chill for a while are you on a
FedEx job and you're like I'm taking the
uniform off I'm gonna go sit down listen
to a podcast [ __ ] yeah what kind of
uniform your [ __ ] ambassador to what
oh you're like one of the security guys
wait oh you guys call them ambassadors
let's classing it up a lot I gotta be
honest yeah it's like I do carry mace
with you know oh okay okay so what like
if I'm getting if I'm on the street and
I'm like I'm lost
oh there's an ambassador excuse me sir
where are the prostitutes in Phoenix
what's the weirdest question you've ever
been asked where the prostitutes and you
go you know what goes six blocks down
take a right
use my name it's Phil they'll [ __ ]
hook you up
you ever been asked that it's a good
question on the streets I was in
Indianapolis last week and I was
sexually assaulted has anyone ever told
you that I was is that a volunteer job
or do you get full-time benefits lots of
benefits you're like lays like hey do
you know where I can find a good time
and you're like yeah right here in my
pants did you see the guy walked by
earlier when I reached were you here
when Ari spheres dick was out well that
was you
oh and you're like I need to go in that
place to investigate further
I didn't yeah okay the devil Lords I
just saw your mouth open the dick shows
that only every three hours so you have
to wait it out I saw you put your you
put your butthole to the glass by the
way great and a great ambassador you are
you're like you just walk by were you
telling people you're like hey if you
want to see a guy slapping his dick and
balls around lockdown [ __ ] ambassador
Arnie over here
you're good ambassador sir yeah by the
way can I borrow your uniform for like
an hour tomorrow
I would love to [ __ ] do that can we
give your name and social over the
airwaves
your name and social security can we
give it out over the airwaves guys a
[ __ ] ambassador did you write that on
your online dating profile ambassador do
you online date yeah like just cuz
you're a city ambassador do you still
have diplomatic immunity okay not really
you might have something do you ever
feel like Batman when you're ambassador
is that what they call it like
ambassador today how many steps do you
take a day
no [ __ ] sir are you are you required to
stand in one spot do they give you like
a circle that you can't step out of all
day are you required to like move he's
an ambassador he's got to move around
town yeah and you're representing
Phoenix you better take that job
seriously do they ever make you dress up
like the Phoenix on gorilla you do
events with the gorillas ever sexual
stuff or just like yeah like you ever do
orgies okay ever anything for the kids
never send you to Burning Man to to
[ __ ] drum a business for Phoenix
alright wish these beers weren't here
don't you see what we do the weirdest
thing ever to split that good alright
let's keep it moving should we go to the
Daily Mail regular kinnexa never let us
down before [ __ ] no let's get oddly
quiet in here and you start getting
self-conscious about it well I stopped
caring about that about 40 minutes ago
is what I say to this crowd and you
afraid to use that at your bachelor job
tomorrow and this is for the guy in the
Hurley show
[Music]
by the way the guy in the Hurley shirt
has distanced himself from his Samoan
friend I think they had a falling-out
yeah did you guys break up what's going
on here
your what just getting closer you were
actually front row and then you move
back there now you're these guys took
your [ __ ] seat remember that girl and
how bad she sucked yeah I hope we see
her later I'm still in my head about it
you have to move on man you got to move
on she's gone now
even Cosby couldn't defeat a woman of it
she'd be talking the whole way through
[Music]
Daily Mail you ready for a Daily Mail I
am ready are you this is a little sad
ambassador to the city Phoenix to the
rest of the world you may cry over this
into your Steven Seagal let's go tea
look at that goatee yeah stand up and
show the crowd and rub it on each of
their chests is that real is that a real
goatee okay not it's not like horse
pubes is the color real colors not row
you colored it in just for men okay
it looks natural I have some gray should
I go with that I'm thinking of going
Brown my black hair my pubes are salt
and pepper like Jay Leno's hair yeah he
pubes with your silver fox let's get
this Daly bail okay so this is a sad
story right away the people listening
that will listen to this at home we're
gonna hate of course the [ __ ] is this
ambassador pass me that delicious Bud
Light Oh
Bud Light tastes great less filling is
that Miller Lite
I think it could work it's
interchangeable so a Russian woman was
on vacation of the Dominican Republic
the old ER yeah good place she got in a
car accident no these guys the guy with
the number one on the side what happened
is the hair on the side growing out too
much it's like I gotta go home and get
that number one again it's really
degrading that you have to watch him
slowly walk out yeah because it's so
much lighting in here that you can just
see him all leave just do it fast
rip the band-aid off just run out I was
Scottie maples who just walked I could
have been so this lady died a Russian
woman died in the Dominican Republic
again she was hanging out of the window
of the car okay on the passenger side
topless okay like I was going well the
driver recorded her on her cell phone
which seems the opposite so the old
classic hang out the window with your
titties out yeah yeah in the dominican
republic yeah and the drivers like hey
don't worry i'll film why should i watch
where we're going yeah yeah natalia
Borodino 35 from moscow just having a
good time no no doesn't say if she knows
Steven Seagal from Russia probably Rob
Lee doesn't she taking her bikini off
was playing up to the camera according
to the article okay seems seems like
it's their opinion she called her top
half out of the car window well the
friend was driving yeah you just said
that is it convertible
[Music]
well there is a picture of it the bad
news is is she's the mother of one okay
so the video shows her with upper body
hanging out of the window of the moving
car before she hits a lamppost there she
is by the way great Bevers those are
beautiful
it's a tough it's tough to lose those
they look fake though they're fake but
they look great but I think you could
repurpose them to a dominican woman yes
that's true transplant yeah anybody on
the donor list this woman looks
horrified who doesn't know about
to show you don't know I mean let's also
admit this lady's a [ __ ] idiot
look at no one out the way this woman
doesn't dive in lamppost she's shoving
her finger in her mouth titties out
you're gonna come to Dominican Republic
and show off with this photo shoot not
expect to get hit by a [ __ ] lamppost
she's licking her finger that right
there that this lady got hit proves that
there is a God but I mean the body
yeah the body's tight look at the fist
guys get ready jerkin are you all right
about there the ambassador's like show
the picture again if he's like if only I
had the superpower of removing black
bars pity he's like I think it's lady
where there was a great taco place once
here she is again
oh she's sucking the finger if you're
like me like [ __ ] yes she does
everybody tough to do somebody loves
[ __ ] in this world it seems like she
was hanging out the window a long time
it's she's really milking this photo
shoot and then they ran into that
fateful lamp oh my god and then it just
did it sever her body what happened if
you want to know where this was in case
you want to miss it the same place it
was Punta Cana you know they put crosses
up where people died we do
brassiere from the lake yeah just put a
bit like a [ __ ] paper mache set of
titties up in a picture of her topless
she would want it that way can I go
there to see the picture it was filmed
by her friend Ivana I was close Ivana
Bora chook 32 she's believed to have
been driving the car why they don't know
I do you want to know what she was
wearing on the bottom I would actually
love Daily Mail do you think MC Hammer
pants no Zubaz she's wearing a pair of
bikini bottoms oh my gosh off from the
picture she playfully sticks her finger
in her mouth and laughs at the camera
playfully but within seconds the video
shows impact oh is the video there oh my
god oh dude no this this way she's got
care that kids before impact she got
careless she's having one of her life
hold back extension Wow you gotta get
the tits looking great you're like that
let me show him off the best I can
she's got good core strength she does
she's
Pilates isn't her first and you know
what look at those perky fake tits just
[ __ ] it staying right in the same
position those are Russia's best goddamn
did it take our head offer to just sever
the whole body limb and say the article
did not say that this is second Oh
before the hit I think that's during the
hit okay you got to show that look at
that is that blood
oh Jesus show the picture I can't do it
if you have a weak stomach
please looked yeah if she was a
beautiful woman show her classic here's
Russian beauty
this is her on the set of the Russian
James Bond film the Russian knockoff
very beautiful woman she Steven Seagal
sexually harassed or allegedly if you
show the picture of the impact I can't
do it
just please make we gave him free beers
we can't who here she is oh it's too bad
she was rushed to the hospital she died
there of serious injuries I'll say those
were pretty serious I mean here's the
thing though ladies and gentlemen if you
have spectacular breasts don't hang them
out the window I like to get cocky about
it he wears the crucifix to show that
she is religious in this picture where
she's looking your fingers almost again
I don't think there's any heaven for
somebody who's topless hanging out of a
car and gets hit by a light pole here's
how Russian News reported it Moskovsky
Komsomolets
said the woman who's having fun
demonstrating her naked breasts while
their computers every demonstrating yeah
here they are this is how the dirt naked
it's like one of those kids books see my
tits see my tits out of a car window god
this [ __ ] how do you explain this to
the child when the child is waiting at
home well he's not at home cuz he was on
vacation with her Oh what is he see - oh
she flips her tits out how much she tell
the kid to cover his eye I'm gonna say
wasn't in the car I hope God let's hope
it's bad enough that this is your mother
oh my god but then it's doubly bad when
you're like hey remember mom's tits were
out and then she hit that lamppost and
got her head ripped off how you know
this lady is known for this sort of
photo yeah hello Inger suck in that
middle finger that would be embarrassing
enough if you were dialed that those
photos are online
and they laid to have the fact that she
was decapitated or I don't know whatever
you what would you call it detent
indicated titties out I call it a
titties out death this guy right now is
glad you're like I'm glad I walked into
this [ __ ] place
this guy's like why can't I be an
ambassador during something like this
find a dead body with the titties out
this is just a dime-a-dozen story now
that [ __ ] an Instagram and social
media man it's just you're here this
ever all the time people go to the
Dominican Republic hanging their titties
out the window and getting [ __ ]
decapitated this is the stupid like why
print this she's originally from
zlatoust know an industrial city in the
Urals then she moved the regional
capital chill bunts kick that is this is
all pertinent information she moved her
up Moscow recently she'd been working in
Cannes France as an estate agent selling
properties to wealthy Russian buyers not
anymore yeah that's over that job has
sailed
so there it is lady's dead it's sad but
it's also a cautionary tale
one less titty flasher in the world yeah
I say at the shame let's see one more
story
I say sixteen more okay that's what you
want where do these people have to go
yeah no you guys have any plans do you
have plans for this tonight ambassador
he's got to get back to being good to do
nothing are you gonna go to be a
diplomat is that your other job how long
you been in basa ting ten years were you
one of the first ambassadors of Phoenix
oh no there was something before you who
was the first what's his name 18-year
veteran let's give a shout out John
Donne is he just the [ __ ] wealth of
knowledge or do you hate him you're like
oh there's done piece of [ __ ] won't
leave if we call the dawn right now I go
what's the best place to take a [ __ ] in
Phoenix would he be like I'll tell you
right now I can name six of them I say
we call them and say this it's done are
you glad you came here sir we're glad
you came here as well
is that was a you know that's with all
three where do we go from here
uh that is a good question there's a lot
of good stuff I'm seeing here yeah
Shengo aliens
yeah well that's decent they go guy in
the thong pulled over she's getting
Glenn's ladies getting Nancy you are you
getting antsy man you guys want to hear
about a drug sniffing dog
you've got thrown out of the if you want
we'll give Glenn a ride home what's that
can you call Ari said can we call Ari
Glenn just leave now you son of a [ __ ]
O'Neill's gonna whip you in this race by
the way Glenn he's your put him into the
wall that's a threat oh yeah that's been
reported see you on the street I'm
pushing you into traffic
we got the [ __ ] ambassadors of the
city on my side we own this town now
once he tells dawn the 18 year vet
Danish you know needle rule the streets
and we have a [ __ ] the tallest
Hispanic man in Phoenix history on our
side yeah who's supposedly friends with
this guy but they haven't seen each
other since he set a load of them this
is the worst reunion I've ever seen it
was like hi and then it's like yeah we
don't he was voted most likely to hit a
man with a machete in high school which
which of the two boys could be the
watcher Hawaii sure it's most likely to
hang out it outside schools too long
I did see doing anything is that base a
good parking spot he supported us when
that woman I know I'm sorry I had shirt
washers the Danish likes you a lot of
people don't know that our names apart
by the way yeah
shirts he looks like a young Paul Scheer
that guy yeah you got a Paul Scheer vibe
no better contacts I was gonna see how
bad your vision was the Ambassador
looked and he's like I'm an ambassador
that guy's white I know it what if I
walked up to you I'm like where's the
nearest Klan rally yet he's like which
one do I pick this is a real question
and that question was [ __ ] he's just
gonna lie do you have to swear an oath
when you go take the ambassadorship I
promise to look good in orange what if I
say where's the nearest glory hole
looking to get this dish sounds like my
house through ha have you ever said my
house but then pointed at your mouth
have you ever told a woman to take out
the gum that she was chewing before she
gave you a [ __ ] yes people anytime
you hesitate that's an automatic yes
just say no right you were going up to
somebody and you were making an
ambassador citizen's arrest can you do
that do you have the authority say you
didn't just say that you don't do that
and they farted in front of you would
you arrest them or would you say do it
in my mouth next time he's an ambassador
what does that mean do you ever abuse
your power I serve me to hashtag too
soon you'll never get like drunk chicks
walking out of the club you're like I'm
an ambassador
time for ambassador Pablo I don't even
know your name sir is it Pablo what's
your name Chuck alright there's not
enough Chuck's in the world Chuck yeah
you get that a lot
everywhere show Taylor's guy is the most
interesting man in the world
[ __ ] that Dos Equis guy it's Chuck the
Ambassador brigade go Chuck yourself
every Chuck meet what the hell's Chuck
meet I don't know all right let's uh
let's let's get this story out these
people have places to go no they don't
what are you doing after the show Chuck
you don't know you came for this you
came for the right reason I'm gonna come
to later did we win a fan over in you
denim jacket lady whoa oh Jesus Christ
you didn't hear that she said I think
you're funny my god and pointed at me Oh
she pointed at me [ __ ] lady if you don't
know it's a part this is the Danish
talking what's your problem with me
what's your problem with me I'm what she
said you're peaking I think that's not a
pregnant term too loud you're spotting
lady you just [ __ ] took the wind out
of my sails he's not your demographic
man that's true he's a Jew lover goecart
client go car cleanse is my demographic
old lady who do you prefer Danish or
O'Neal both good answer I was weak good
answer I like this lady [ __ ] hates me
I like her
now I'm fixated on there it's the Hat
yeah he looks like a racist doesn't he
oh you know what oh right now because I
have longer hair and it's coming out the
back I look like basically the most
hated person in the [ __ ] country
right now a Midwestern white male let's
kill O'Neal who's with me hey good luck
trying alright let's wrap it up on this
this is from the Sun The Daily Mail's
rival a Eurocentric show I know it's all
Europe number one Aaron left us to hang
the [ __ ] dry and we had all those
sound problems yeah [ __ ] cut out for
like 20 minutes can't believe you thanks
a lot Erin punch-drunk treats you like
[ __ ] we've done nothing but nice been
nice to you did you get the gift basket
we sent yeah edible arrangements you can
eat we got nice we got sharise berry
sent to you yeah Dober zone so this is a
lady I'm hoping this gets you enraged to
win back this lady I don't want her
anymore I think this is gonna win her
back for you by the way I don't want you
to listen to this podcast I do Oh what
is this hatred towards me Jesus Christ
he doesn't speak for the both of us come
on board he'll win you over maybe live
maybe live isn't your thing maybe
listening at home look at these people
come on in hi
don't wave to us just walk in I think
they're next oh they are okay never mind
I apologize there's a guy with a suit
that just hooked in okay so this ladies
or not
this is not the podcast you're looking
for if you're wearing a suit I believe
this is taking us to Australia so this
lady Kimberly Williams unleashed a
scathing review of a transparent gym
clothes wha
she wore Puma leggings okay and she said
they were completely see-through
she says the company
to introduce booty tests on their items
before they hit stores so this lady just
put on crystal clear leggings she wore
the hip there the like Jesus those are
look at the ass crack oh my god
in her defense they are pretty
see-through what's the other outfit
she's wearing the white thing is that
like a back support it's like a thong
shirt it's like a tank top oh my god
so she's a 27 year old nanny
yeah well firstly which sounds weird
only that's how we talk here I was
pretty annoyed that I bought brought a
new pair of gym tights they were
completely see-through I've not worn
them since they're pretty much just
sitting in my draw I've been able to
return them also as they were sale item
something tells me if you could see your
[ __ ] through them you probably have a
case for returning them maybe you
shouldn't have bought them on sale
that's true
said you would only expect this and
cheap made leggings but wouldn't have
expected it from Puma they are a sport
aware company who bought tota a higher
[ __ ] level who would honestly want to
buy them knowing you can see everything
no normal person would by the way why is
she posting this on social media you
could literally see her [ __ ] look she
wanted to be offended twice damn yep
still see-through it's [ __ ] crazy
she's a former personal trainer she only
realized why she was getting funny looks
from people when a friend pointed it out
that's learning she thought she was just
killing in terms of comedy but it turns
out her ass was showing the whole day oh
she's from London she wrote a post to
Pumas official Facebook page which is
how you expressed your opinion about the
incident she posted a photo as evidence
to ask of a conducted booty test on
their products but the company never
responded how would they conduct a booty
but they just get a bunch of chicks in
there to [ __ ] bend over wearing them
I guess yeah that's what she feel like
hey can you see my [ __ ] no you're
good all right let's put these out in
the market she says describing the
traumatic event I don't think it's that
dramatic to be honest but she said it
was a cold London morning oh This Is
England there's a cold London morning
and I had taken myself shopping to buy
some new gym leggings as I sorted
through the racks of leggings upon
leggings is simply a stylish black Puma
leggings come on
it said leggings about 18 we get there
leggings I decided to do it and purchase
myself a nice pair of Puma gym tights
Saturday morning I sprung out of bed an
utter excitement to show off these new
black uma leggings she had as I waltz
down to the gym not a care in the world
I could feel her eyes on me sounds like
a shitty novel yeah what is it
[ __ ] romance novel people are
clearing checking out the new leggings I
had purchased and I digged it was like
look at this lady's ass ready for my
Tabata class with the Tabata class I
don't know is it like tobogganing mixed
in with Zumba I was like tobogganing
mixed in with like ciabatta bread
somehow I was feeling super energized
and super stylish and my new puma
leggings once again maybe a sponsorship
of like this ladies really [ __ ] going
for it as I bent down to stretch out my
legs my friend gasped another shock came
I can see your arse
she's always offensive to me when you
say hearts I prefer ass or [ __ ] she
checked her leg you prefer [ __ ] yeah
over arse
I do like Kim I could see her [ __ ]
yeah then you're like oh my god she said
she looked in the mirror and she was
disgusted much to my disgust as I bent
over in my new gym tights my whole arse
was showing through my simple yet
stylish Puma gym leggings why did you
keep saying that oh my god how could
this happen to me I thought to myself
where Puma out to humiliate me yeah Puma
targeted you specifically lady everybody
at the company was like I can't wait for
this [ __ ] pair of tights to be so
sold and then we're all gonna laugh at
her when's Kim gonna buy these we've
been waiting for it for years she said I
asked you Puma do you booty test your
items before they hit the stores once
again what kind of [ __ ] question is
that how do I know if I can trust your
products again from not giving my whole
gym a view of my ever so peachy arse
lady just [ __ ] go to a different
brand switch it up yeah get off the sale
racks if anything you learned you got to
buy the full price item it's true said
she tried to laugh off the situation but
she was still annoyed at Puma and their
lack of a response like [ __ ] you lady
luckily I have a sense of humor so I
laughed it off and made my friend go
behind me in our gym class so at least
she had a view of my bum as opposed to
the whole gym class so he's the [ __ ]
worst
she here this lady was here yeah she was
coming she knew that we were going to do
this story should I think Puma should
possibly looking at how they qua quality
test their materials before putting
products out to be sold
it's really ruined this lady's life yeah
by the way don't [ __ ] wear tights out
in public man like it's not a [ __ ]
it's not a piece of clothing that you
should just be wearing out so I don't
mind that but if it's like if you get
one bad pair it doesn't ruin the whole
but more if they're all like genre
somebody tells me they're all like that
well guys like if you wear sweatpants
everyone can see your dick but it's just
pants you wear a hole cut out for your
dick yeah you don't wear those
no I don't wear those when I see an
ambassador in Phoenix I want them to see
what I'm working with you're like can
you tell me some great places where I
could take my [ __ ] right now excuse me
sir do you have any food that would
match this see where I can get a bun put
my [ __ ] in it who a spokesperson said
Puma offers leggings of different
materials and it's product ranges k2 new
wide variety of consumer preferences in
case maybe you got too much booty for
those also what size did she buy maybe
she bought the wrong size and just
stretched the pants to the limit
I don't know push it to the limit she
said they said in case a customer is
unhappy or dissatisfied with the quality
of a puma product purchase we have a
return policy in place that guarantees
that the product will be replaced or
refund it but you can't refund her
humility we always like to end on a not
a strong note yes because that way
you'll tune in next week to be like do
these guys pull themselves out of the
hole or are our heroes going to be
defeated what is this an old-school
Batman epic yeah I'm actually a little
too drunk right now to continue really
yeah
I've had a lot of drinks how many drinks
lady no don't give me [ __ ] guns we're
not buddies what's that the Cubs the
Cubs I gave up on the Cubs years ago wow
I think you hate white males from the
Midwest is that true miss
I look like this [ __ ] guy do you hate
him which guy the guy are you with him
are you with your boyfriend okay just
two pals you guys gonna stop being
friends with her after this these guys
oh well we do say these guys are like
bizarro Danish no Neil right here you're
like us from another world I like your
style they're way smaller Jesus Christ
I did I did feel superior in that moment
I think they're bigger how tall are you
guys I'm five nine O'Neal's five nine
I'm five 90s that come up here you're
five nine I'll tell are you ambassador
yeah you know get a lot of people throw
in the half-inch in there they usually
just round up I like your honesty you
know what he is he's five six that's why
he's five and a half it's true
all right well we can either get out on
a sour note or we could roll or roll the
dice em one more
where's Doug Benson can he piss on us
real quick we have to get someone to
piss on the show it seemed the Hurley
guy why don't we get to while we get
Hurley guys buddy to piss on Hurley
reunited with his friend from sir when
you piss it's like a goddamn fire hose
welcome you could probably [ __ ] knock
out an i with the force that you're
pissing who are you talking to I'm
talking about [ __ ] goatee right there
the giant yeah what do you do for a
living giant man why are you looking at
Hurley like easier but you're like tell
me really just give me tell me something
are you high we're cops sir you have to
answer us
we're gonna have you blow on our wieners
to see if you're on drugs right now what
do you do for work are you an ambassador
are you his rival are you Don
are you Don the 18-year vat of the
ambassadorship program what do you do
logistics it's in the gallery [ __ ]
vague unemployed you're like you know
some logistics well something here and
there sounds like a guy who cooks
crystal meth and like the desert is that
true do you want to kill either one of
us if you had to which one would you
kill me Jesus Christ wait my writer
you're right him Oh me you just got here
you want to kill me why you know what I
like this guy what did he say he said
you said choose which one would dies man
so I choose you which one would dies
yeah you're gonna choose for him I came
in with a lot of confidence yeah no [ __ ]
one rollerblading helmet and a hell of a
lot of confidence what the [ __ ] who
wants to kill this guy who just got here
even this guy he raised his own hand
he's like I'm ready to commit suicide
this is my last night to live why do you
think he's not wearing the helmet sir
have you ever done the topless selfies
out of a fast moving car we all wish you
did is that oh you're Zen on your bucket
list
this guy raised his hey hey I know a
great road in the Dominican Republic
that you can go down to take it we
weren't saying it's the wrong country
he said Dominican Republic and you said
I'm not Puerto Rican this is why you
don't keep an unlocked door at a podcast
yeah you get riffraff where where are
you coming from sir oh that explains it
having go ambassador where where take
this guy out of Phoenix
weirdo Wow what are you a mind reader
how'd you know he's gonna ask that
we're not from here Puerto Rican
Dominican guy I don't know we're having
gales at I don't even know what Street
him on I have to ask the ambassador how
I get back to my hotel he tucks me in at
night that's his job yes okay washes my
[ __ ] before I go to bed oh you took
it too far that's why she doesn't like
that's fine that's where I go you know
what I'm always gonna take it too far
there's one thing he shoots one thing
the goecart Glenn knows I'm gonna take
it too [ __ ] far you know it's the
fourth you solar system shirt who just
got here he said there you go yeah what
are you coming from the set of stranger
things that [ __ ] shirt you're so high
your life I had to [ __ ] find a safe
place to sit down
should we put this guy on a mic no
absolutely not yeah are you kidding me
[ __ ] worst mistake not putting you on
a mic you just said you had hurt your
[ __ ] feelings he said no insensitive
man in the world he wanted to kill me
sir he said he gonna kill himself scouts
have raised hands so he wanted to kill
himself he deserves it if you do it just
pull down your pants make it look like
auto-erotic asphyxiation that way your
parents and your family won't be like Oh
what could we have done to stop em like
you just love jerking off that all the
fixin's was actually a mistake Oh what
does that mean I didn't mean to do it
okay
[ __ ] solar systems in my head look at
these two guys back here you guys
brothers there's three guys back there
Oh three you guys that's your brother
all right
oh one of them's like an albino one is
black hair different fathers different
mothers same vagina who's the other guy
with you oh cool
[ __ ] roommates man good story you
ever catch this guy jerking off in the
shower Jesus won't you mind your own
[ __ ] business well you always barge
into it hey you jerking off in here just
open the [ __ ] door go in says the guy
who spies on his neighbors what do you
want me to do what do you mean I
believing my house and this guy's
beatnik you're looking out there for it
now I am
but I originally was just ambushed by
this court McAllen ladies and gentlemen
you saw it once and now you just can't
stop looking hey no it's like a [ __ ]
car crash except he's telling off his
balls court McGowan just walked in here
to get a water he was so parched
he was so cheap he wouldn't buy his own
water how's it coming to come in here
and find it [ __ ] free water all right
we're just looking for a dismount here
there is none we need Aaron's help
remember when Aaron left us I do
remember that there are you back you
with us you invested in this show again
yeah I'm here okay oh I do is that your
first participation in a podcast here no
let's go through here actually so
ambassador what do you rate this show
scale of one to ten
thank you eight stars from the air eight
for him but not a zero man for me yeah
negative two for you down to eight lady
this is called do you know how you've
injured me do all the tell us that we're
still by the way we're doing a stand-up
show over here at 11:45 yeah at stand-up
live if you want to come check that out
we'll be over there this lady's like
okay I wanna go home
get a glass of red wine sit in the
bathtub you're gonna go you're like I'll
just [ __ ] go all right we've waited
this long I'll just [ __ ] go see the
show do you drive you have to work at
4:00 am doing whoosh it stock groceries
for II am pleased to deliver groceries
go car Glen would you take this woman
home for Christ's sake Wow his go-kart
is not he's charging it it's parked give
a shifter card ambassador are you
allowed to drive go-karts through the
City of Phoenix they give you a Segway
they don't give you anything
can I get us could I ride a horse
through the streets of Phoenix I could I
don't need any sort of permit does it
need like a basket to catch the horse
[ __ ] no you can sit right on the street
of your horse
Yeah right what are those the [ __ ]
ambassadors you have an ambassador who
takes care of horse [ __ ] you have a
streetscape team Phoenix has thought of
everything yeah no [ __ ] Wow seriously
yeah there's literally no [ __ ] in the
streets say I had a dog and a [ __ ] in
the street and I didn't pick it up what
were the ambassadors have to say about
that
that's it and what if we didn't do it
you couldn't enforce it they tell you to
take care of it oh oh you'd call the
[ __ ] screw the [ __ ] SWAT team Phoenix is
a very passive-aggressive City and it's
true how many years have you lived here
okay do you know that guy she go to high
school together and that wasn't because
I think you're both Latin it was just a
question so don't be racist everybody I
wasn't saying you I was looking at some
of these people some people judgmental
eyes this [ __ ] rollerblader oh my god
so there's a party across the street at
like Sun and laws bar I think there's a
girl there who love you yeah oh Jesus I
like how you say it loud but you cover
your mouth like you're gonna whisper are
you like one of those homeless kids from
Portland and it comes to here for the
winter anyone have a skateboard we can
beat this guy with yeah feel like you
were in the movie kids yeah it's way
before your time we should check it out
wait how old are you don't even know
what year it came out sir you don't even
know it you're like a wave of all right
I'm gonna come out last year yeah I got
three traumas you're bored look at me
what does this [ __ ] price is right I
could have as many tries as I want
you're 23 you're fourteen thirteen a
49-0
oh Jesus you're way too old to be
wearing that shirt I know that this
could be the ambassador's son you're
cool oh good it's got a real kick out of
this lady
cooler than me it's debatable sir it's
very debatable in your mind not these
two brothers behind you they're about
ready to curb stop you outside American
History X style I think it's the albino
who's got the anger
he's a pale man would you punch this guy
out from behind he's not wearing his
helmet Jesus he's like [ __ ] yeah I would
I'd break his brainstem what vehicle
look what are you driving that you need
a helmet where is it it's outside wait
inside where you know I was his attempt
at humor it was terrible
do you really I don't know if I think it
was are you a rickshaw driver my god
Phoenix did you just get out of night
school or something what are you guys
insane all right hey we're gonna need
you just [ __ ] murder this guy well
I'll keep our mouth shut
well I've been Danish this is O'Neill
we're gonna take off everybody let me
cue but there's another podcast after us
right there is but we're gonna take off
yeah let's get out of here shall we
we shall you're gonna play the outro
song stick around
danish own you babies you know me
grantee hearts they will steal
Danish Indomie
[Music]
uh did you end it already okay well
special thanks to stand-up live the
Tempe improv and Chico Malo we had lunch
there earlier oh is that where we had it
yeah well the place is great it was
tremendous yeah this is what I ordered
because when you're drinking the blue
guys soup you don't know that you're
gonna your mouth won't stop getting very
high the spicy [ __ ] soup thank you
everybody thank you thank you guys
[Applause]